une production du studio SF
bienvenue sans filtre le podcast où on
parle avec nos invités
avec moi dôme plante cette semaine on
est rendu à notre Kill Bill Volume 2 tu
es
des élections
provinciales on avait fait l'épisode 1
la semaine passée là on fait l'épisode 2
en abordant en question d'un autre point
de vue ouais un point de vue un petit
peu plus appliqué à la on a parlé
beaucoup la semaine passée de
comportement des électeurs et qu'est-ce
qui fait qu'on vote pour un parti ou
pour l'autre là des parties des
plateformes qu'est-ce qu'un propose
versus l'autre qu'est-ce qui fonctionne
qu'est-ce qui fonctionne pas c'était
vraiment super intéressant on a reçu
Olivier Jacques qui professeur adjoint
département de gestion d'évaluation et
des politiques de santé à l'école de
santé publique d'une versée Montréal toi
tu leur tenue par cœur tenue par cœur
pour ça en audio puis chercheur aussi
post de chorale à l'université
un gars qui connaît la politique sur le
bout de ses doigts c'était vraiment
super fascinant d'entendre parler il va
pas avec le dos de la main morte de
temps en temps sur certaines
propositions des parties qui avec le dos
de la même mort
le dos de la mémoire mais oui
sur certaines propositions des parties
s'il trouve ce que ça tient pas la route
ou que c'est ridicule ils se gêne au
repas de le dire puis en fait il écorché
un petit peu tous les patrouilles au
passage également dans certains plus que
d'autres mais quand même un peu tous les
parties enfin que c'était vraiment super
intéressant puis aussi en sens
tous les bons coups des parties aussi
factures je pense qu'il y a
lui évidemment il y a peut-être des
partis pris mais c'est vous pouvez quand
même former votre propre opinion en
écoutant ça on a pris thème par thème
santé éducation immigration
environnement environnement éducation
éducation je l'ai dit dès qu'on a tout
ça puis je pense que si vous avez soit
soit pas une déclare de vraiment
qu'est-ce que les parties proposent tant
que ça un versus l'autre c'est quoi les
différences majeures c'est quoi les
philosophie majeures de ces parties-là
je pense que vraiment ça vaut vous
éclairer puis je pense que vous allez
avoir besoin aussi c'était un bon
podcast on a réussi à le téléphone un
gars c'est un super bon comme ça c'est
pas drôle c'était ben plaisant on a
parlé aussi du parce que là on parle
beaucoup de c'est des dépenses puis d'où
les promesses électorales mais on a su
parler des entrées prenez où ta jambe
vous le prenez ou cet argent là
le cours porte-parole le Québec
solidaire pense que l'argent pose d'un
arbre mais on s'en va dans les arts ou
pousse l'argent pour essayer de
comprendre
où cet argent-là des promesses parce
qu'on entend beaucoup parler de
promesses tout le temps et puis là on
veut voir où est-ce que ça ce que ça
représente c'est mon temps là superbe
conversation puis on espère que vous
allez aimer ça encore une fois
intéressez-vous à ça allez voter le 3
bientôt l'Europe c'est bientôt quand que
ça ça sort c'est la semaine prochaine
let's go dans le fond
[Musique]
belle soirée électorale moi je me
commande la pizza
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parfait ben écoute on commence salut
allô ça va bien ça va bientôt
je veux juste commencer le avant qu'on
se lance dans le vif du sujet là
piquer souvent
[Musique]
j'ai toujours pas digéré l'échange
compte web ah ouais mais on se rappelle
tous de deux de ces buts le but
et le gros Slapshot compte Boston en
2011 avec le bâton
moi je me rappelle surtout c'est c'est
mis en échec les gens d'ailleurs la mise
en échecs
je pense qu'il y avait renversé
auverskin complètement sur son dos puis
il avait comme levé là le problème la
mise en échec par le dos c'est quand que
le GoPal il est passé ouais c'est ça
mais tu vois moi moi je je l'avais
digéré cet échange là puis au final tu
crois est-ce que tu crois plus on n'est
pas en politique loin de là mais parce
que je sais que sur un tableau Twitter
tu vas être One Piece analyse de hockey
oui
je vous le dis encore une fois RDS TVA
sport vous me donner une job moi je
quitte l'université
[Rires]
mais moi je pense qu'au final ça a comme
été le Canadien on est sorti gagnant
j'ai l'impression de cette échange là à
la fin de l'histoire ouais on a été
surpris parce qu'il y a plus le
péricliter plus vite qu'on pensait et on
a été chanceux web prennent sa retraite
plutôt compensée
de le récupérer pour une raison qu'on
ignorait mais est-ce que tu crois que
cette espèce de
dégénérescence de piquer souvent c'est
quelque chose que les gens du Canadiens
ont pu voir venir
le contrat quand même été signé il y a
longtemps ouais c'est c'est je pense
arriver plus vite qu'on pensait
même pas je pense de 13 ans
je pense que c'est un gars qui jouait
physiquement
mais on aurait quand même aimé ça
l'avoir comme sixième DEP cette année à
Montréal
[Musique]
RDS la perche il est lancé
que vous parliez c'est ça
ton parcours un peu puis qu'est-ce qui
te Bella
c'est quoi ton background mettant
académique oui ben moi je suis un
politologue donc je suis vraiment
sciences politiques à l'université
Montréal d'abord puis il y a
l'université maguile ensuite mais j'ai
été recruté par l'école de santé
publique pour être finalement leur
politologue de service pour parler de
politique publique de Sciences Po dans
le cadre du système de santé au Québec
et je me spécialise principalement
finances publiques donc
pourquoi les gouvernements décident de
taxer de dépenser pour qui à qui ça
bénéficie etc
et j'ai toujours été intéressé la
politique en général quand j'étais plus
jeune je voulais être attaché politique
j'ai eu une brève expérience et
je me suis dit que la carrière
académique était plus pour moi est-ce
que tu as le droit de dévoiler une brève
expérience politique
dans quel milieu ecoute c'était un stage
qui s'appelle le stage parlementaire un
programme de ça je parlementaire Ottawa
c'est vraiment intéressant ça te permet
de choisir pour quelle des petites va
travailler et ça te force à travailler
pour le gouvernement et l'opposition
donc j'ai eu la chance de travailler
pour un député du gouvernement
harperon c'était très intéressant
d'aller là-bas ensuite j'avais la
critique en finance d'une [ __ ] péguinage
centre-ville de Toronto donc c'était
complètement différent comme expérience
ça permettait de voir un peu les deux
côtés des bonnes discussions avec My
Lake le conservateur pour lequel je
travaillais franchement
il aimait pas l'assurance emploi
puis il y a beaucoup les hadminton ça
c'est ce que je vous rappelle demain
et beaucoup de gens ok oui mais Mike
c'est un gars qui travaillait pour les
avant ah ouais ok mais il y avait pas de
connaitre dans le temps
le passage à video c'était ouais c'est
ça c'était pas de sa faute
c'est que là tu décides de revenir de
retour à l'université en fait après
c'est ça c'était après ma maîtrise et
puis je m'étais dit peut-être que c'est
le temps d'aller voir qu'est-ce qui se
passe dans le vrai monde et là
finalement je me suis dit finalement je
veux retourner dans la tour du bois
c'est plus facile le prénom c'est de la
merde mais honnêtement c'est ça qui est
le fan de l'étudier tu sais c'est ça
c'est pas obligé d'être dans le vrai
monde
on voulait on voulait te recevoir ici
dans le fond parce que
l'objectif du sans filtre c'est c'est
nous complaire nous-mêmes premièrement
mais c'est aussi de rendre certaines
certains concepts certaines choses de
justifier certaines affaires puis quand
on a la chance de recevoir des
universitaires ou des chercheurs ou des
observateurs politiques par exemple ça
permet vraiment de
mieux saisir plusieurs enjeux puis j'ai
l'impression surtout auprès de notre
génération ou peut-être même les plus
jeunes générations comme si j'étais
encore coulé branché dans le début 20
ans mais mais c'est pas ça mais le 18 34
mettons
la politique c'est
on dirait que ça le pas ça ne va pas
intéressé parce qu'on dirait que c'est
trop complexe c'est trop de personnes
qui disent trop d'affaires qui sont trop
difficiles à saisir mes pompes c'est
difficile de le voir dans notre vie de
tous les jours puis de sentir que notre
vote notre opinion compte puis on
voulait voir avec toi dans le fond
qu'est-ce que ça représente parce que là
le début de la campagne on fait juste
entendre des des promesses
d'investissement c'est juste ça chaque
fois chaque jour les parties ont font
une conférence de presse dans un nouveau
village du Québec pour annoncer qu'il y
a 40 millions qui s'en va qui a 20
millions qui s'en va
300 millions pour les psychologues plus
ce n'est que ça puis on a aucune idée
qu'est-ce que ça représente qu'est-ce
d'où vient cet argent-là qu'est-ce qui
réaliste qu'est-ce qui l'est pas puis
c'est top en symbole de se retrouver
mettons là je vois ça puis je suis quand
même ça activement peut-être plus que la
moyenne des gens de mon âge en tout cas
de ma génération mais je trouve ça quand
même
vraiment difficile comme saisir tout
seul la question du réalisme c'est
vraiment à ça parce que des fois on
dirait que un va dire ben moi je vais
mettre 50 millions là-dedans ah ouais 50
millions mais moi je mets 75 ans
c'est comme c'est quoi le bon chiffre
puis c'est quand c'est ou qui prend cet
argent là c'est vraiment possible de
promettre ça
c'est bien beau aussi mettez un milliard
mettez deux milliards partout mais tu
sais c'est
infinie mais tu sais c'est quand même
c'est pas simple
il n'était pas justement il y avait
comme des zéro de passer
hier avec avec Mika c'est drôle c'est
drôle quand on parle de ça parce que
j'ai réalisé que c'était vraiment un bon
gag que quand il y a des années 60 il
demande un milliard que tout le monde se
marie en disant dans cette somme
d'argent là n'existe pas quand il sera
mort des années 90 il demande un million
tout le monde se marie grandissant genre
trop peu
mais justement les millions de milliards
c'est une bonne chose
du Québec c'est 130-140 milliards en ce
moment ça a augmenté le budget global
mettons l'argent disponible maintenant
la dépense annuelle au Québec c'est
130-140 milliards ok plus des
investissements en infrastructure qui
compte pas dans le budget qui sont dit
c'est comme ben c'est pour réparer une
route qui va être utile dans le futur
genre fait que ça ça compte pas dans le
budget donc on parle vraiment de le
budget de programme c'est 130 milliards
par année donc quand on parle de 10
millions
ça représente pas grand chose des
promesses conséquentes là parle il faut
qu'on parle d'une augmentation de
dépenses de plusieurs centaines de
millions voir quelques milliards ça
c'est conséquent
c'est ça parce que sinon moi des 10
millions on peut en mettre dans beaucoup
de programmes avant que ça commence à
coûter cher puis juste là tu parles de
du budget du Québec et qu'on avait reçu
Eric Girard justement le ministre des
Finances il nous expliquait que il y
avait comme 40% de ceux qui allaient en
santé directement
après ça je pense être éducation en
raison de comme 20% là ou quelque chose
comme ça puis la troisième dépense parce
qu'on en entend parler beaucoup pendant
le pendant la campagne actuelle c'était
les intérêts de la est-ce que c'est
exactes
mais oui je te demandais pas le double
checker je te demandais juste de me
double checker moi parce que j'ai pas je
me rappelle plus on est dans le 40 à peu
près 40 45 en santé puis ça c'est appelé
accroître ça c'est le gros défi du
Québec là il y a deux gros défis que les
politiciens abordent moyen parce que
c'est des défis à long terme c'est les
dépenses de santé vont augmenter parce
que la population vieillit puis parce
que les choses en santé coûtent plus
cher pourquoi il coûte cher parce que on
découvre des nouveaux traitements puis
on veut les avoir parce que ça sauve des
vies donc ça coûte plus cher mais c'est
parce qu'on soigne plus de monde il y a
des nouveaux traitements pour le cancer
qui existe maintenant qui n'était pas de
5 ans c'est bien mais c'est pas donné et
il y a plus de gens qui vieillis donc il
y a plus de gens qui tombent malades
donc ça coûte plus cher donc ça c'est un
défi assez important donc la proportion
des dépenses de santé dans le budget va
augmenter donc ça va coûter plus cher
puis ensuite il y a la question
environnementale qui est l'autre gros
défi qui ça aussi augmente les coûts
juste on parle de réparer des routes
mettons en Gaspésie qui sont qui
subissent l'érosion mais ça c'est ça
coûte cher les villes demande 2
milliards par année pour se préparer
pour préparer leurs infrastructures ou
au changement climatique juste quand il
y a des inondations à Montréal ben ça
veut dire qu'il faut qu'on ait par
exemple faut faire des rénovations des
goûts pour s'assurer que l'eau s'écoule
mieux donc ça c'est des coûts qui vont
qui vont augmenter mais oui 40% santé 20
% éducation service la dette c'est un
gros truc mais c'est aussi parce que les
autres dépenses ensuite c'est des plus
petites catégories tu vas voir mettons
famille c'est en étant important on
donne beaucoup d'argent en famille on
donne des services de garde mais ça va
représenter peut-être 4-5 milliards au
total alors que service de la dette ça
c'est c'est relativement élevé mais
c'est plus plus sous contrôle que ça a
déjà été
on pourrait sûrement partir par
absolument toutes les directions là pour
pour avoir la conversation qu'on
s'apprête à avoir
j'aimerais poser la question
depuis le début de la campagne
tous les partis exceptés Québec
solidaire à moins que je me trompe on
proposait
une une promesse de baisse d'impôts
carrément de de remise gouvernementale
dans les poches des Québécois moi de
comment je le perçois ça semble de quoi
tu supportes électoraliste puis on
dirait que c'est
peu responsable
je te pose la question
Quels sont les promesses des des partis
puis comment est-ce que ça se traduit
dans un budget parce que je peux
comprendre que c'est pour lutter contre
l'inflation je comprends mais est-ce que
ça fonctionne puis est-ce que c'est
possible c'est faisable
on commence par l'inflation
c'est que
l'inflation là c'est causée par la
guerre en Ukraine le fait qu'il y a eu
des brides dans les chaînes
d'approvisionnement que le monde on
comme arrêter de consommer en 2020-2021
et que leur revenu augmenter parce que
je n'ai pas de chose puis le
gouvernement leur donner de l'argent
donc ça ça crée l'inflation le
gouvernement du Québec peut pas faire
grand-chose comme ça
c'est donc c'est la réalité donc ce que
tu peux faire c'est donner de l'argent
aux gens pour qu'il puisse passer au
travail de l'inflation ensuite on peut
se demander est-ce que des gens qui
gagnent 100000 dollars par année on
vraiment sont vraiment affectés par
l'inflation
oui mais en même temps
plus d'argent tu es plus là c'est un peu
tu es plus là c'est un peu exactement
donc l'oeil il y a différentes mesures
qui ont été proposées puis effectivement
tout le monde propose un peu de donner
des chèques à des gens ce qui est
différent d'une baisse d'impôts les
chèques c'est on va y aller une fois on
va te donner d'un chèque à la prochaine
année par exemple là il y a quand même
des différences le PQ propose un chèque
qui est vraiment vraiment généreux pour
les gens qui ont moins d'argent c'est si
tu gagnes en bas de 50000 dollars c'est
1200 et 750$ pour les gens qui gagnent
50 et 80000 dollars et rien pour les
autres donc ça c'est c'est beaucoup
d'argent quand même mais ça coûte cher
mais ça c'est une fois mais ça
représente combien mettons on se situe à
peu près le prix de ça c'est une dans le
sens si tu marginal sur le budget au
complet puis non c'est pas mais c'est
marginal sur le budget parce que c'est
une fois mais ça ça coûte 6 milliards de
dollars
c'est très cher c'est pas le montant de
surplus que dans les coffres de l'État à
cause de l'inflation justement ah mais
ça c'est intéressant effectivement le
fait que toute coûte plus cher ça
augmente les revenus de l'État parce que
les salaires ont aussi cru on en parle
pas mais les salaires ont augmenté à peu
près au niveau de l'inflation dans le
secteur privé au Québec
et donc les salaires croisent donc les
impôts augmentent et les taxes à la
consommation augmente donc oui l'état
fait de l'argent mais
s'il va avoir une récession qui va être
créée donc tu es on peut leur donner au
monde suite mais on va en avoir besoin
plus tard ça c'est première chose mais
oui si à peu près c'est gains là de 6
milliards mais la situation fiscale du
gouvernement du Québec en ce moment elle
paraît bien à cause de l'inflation mais
dans les faits elle ne sera pas si bien
que ça après la prochaine récession là
puis pendant l'avoir une mais oui donc 6
milliards quand même beaucoup la CAC
aussi propose un chèque comme ça le
Parti libéral aussi là où ça se
distingue c'est qu'il y en a qui m'ont
proposé des bases d'impôts récurrentes
en plus ce qui est différent parce que
le 6 milliard que le PQ propose de
redonner aux gens c'est one time
c'est pas très très grave la dépense qui
est arrivée une fois gouvernement
fédéral pendant par exemple pendant la
pandémie vraiment dépenser beaucoup one
time c'est vraiment beaucoup d'argent
qui ont mis mais ça arrive une fois donc
leur situation est moins pire trois ans
plus tard disons et là ben la baisse
d'impôts c'est sûr que ce que ça fait
c'est que ça réduit la capacité de payer
de l'État il y a quelque chose quand tu
parlais d'électoralisme s'il y a quelque
chose d'extrêmement cynique dans ce que
la CAQ propose c'est-à-dire de dire bon
on va baisser les impôts mais on va pas
vous mettre de l'avant les problèmes que
ça implique la baisse d'impôt c'est à
dire une baisse des services publics
parce que en gros là tu payes moins
d'impôts tu as moins de choses qui est
toujours celle-là ou le contribuable
futur moins de service public si tu
payes ta baisse d'impôts par les taxes
par une pardon par la dette donc ce
qu'on observe là c'est ce que la carte a
proposé de faire finalement c'est de
baisser les impôts
en augmentant la dette ce que ce qui
disent en parlant du fond des
générations le font des générations
c'est simplement un le LACAQUE comme dit
on va baisser les impôts en diminuant
l'argent qu'on donne à chacun nos Fonds
des générations le fond des générations
c'est simplement un outil pour réduire
la dette publique donc en gros si on
simplifie on fait que les générations
futures payent pour la baisse d'impôts
maintenant c'est ce qu'on sait ce que la
carte vous propose
en tant que jeune qui gagne moins
d'argent que la moyenne généralement
parce que ton salaire augmente à travers
le temps ben ça ce que ça veut dire
c'est que toi tu vas payer plus d'impôts
plus tard quand tu vas gagner plus
d'argent c'est ça que ça fait là c'est
où tu vas recevoir moins de choses plus
tard ou tu veux payer plus d'impôts plus
tard c'est ça
que j'aime c'est évident que c'est pas
bon parce que ton salaire augmente
jusqu'à 50 ans
tu vas gagner tu vas payer plus moins
d'impôts maintenant mais la perte va
être plus grande plus tard on en parlait
hier
on essaie de garder en tête que
finalement peut-être qu'on veut voter
pour les intérêts du collectif c'est
plus que plus que juste notre propre
intérêt fait que je comprenne quand on
est jeune cette proposition là de la CAQ
fais pas de sens mais ce qui fait du
sens au sens de des finances publiques
ou non ben la question des baisses
d'impôts c'est c'est vraiment une
question de gauche ou de droite quand
est à droite tu veux que le gouvernement
soit plus petit puis donne moins de
services pour que tu payes moins
d'impôts pour avoir plus d'argent dans
tes poches et faire les choix de ce que
tu veux te procurer comme service comme
service finalement que ça soit une
voiture une TV ou une assurance privée
en gros c'est ça avoir moins d'impôt
c'est ce que ça veut dire ce que la
Gauche propose c'est plus de dépenses
publiques donc plus d'impôts et ça
revient vraiment un trader qui est assez
sur ta consommation personnelle
finalement quand tu es dans une société
où il y a plus d'impôts plus de services
publics mais tu reçois plus de choses à
l'état donc tu as des meilleurs services
publics d'éducation santé si tu perds ta
job tu vas ils vont ça va mieux et tes
routes pour être meilleur versus une
société où tu payes moins d'impôts mais
est-ce que ça veut dire c'est que tu as
des moins bons services publics donc tu
vas sûrement devoir te les acheter sur
le marché que ça soit par exemple via de
l'éducation privée ou de la santé privée
mais tu vas avoir plus d'argent aussi
pour tâcher des choses donc tu vas avoir
plus de choses c'est à dire tu vas
pouvoir aller plus au resto pour acheter
un plus gros char ou acheter une plus
grosse TV c'est ça que c'est le c'est
pas plus compliqué que ça donc ensuite
faire plus de choses si tu as de
l'argent mais si tu as pas d'argent je
veux dire tu peux avoir plus de choses
et pas service public exactement oui
tout à fait effectivement dans l'idée de
dans une société avec plus de taxes plus
de services publics les pauvres sont
bedrofs
mais la classe moyenne elle est riche
moins de choses
c'est ça que c'est mais si on peut le
simplifier comme ça c'est ça la vie
c'est ça exactement qu'on mettait juste
pour le pour le fun puis pour quelqu'un
qui
qui suivrait moins ça si on plaçait
mettons les parties sur cette axe là on
les placerait comment mais là c'est
qu'il y a la définition gauche droite
est-ce complexifie mais ce que la CAQ
essaye de dire puis on peut tout à fait
tort c'est que il y a deux parties qui
sont plus extrêmes c'est à dire que QS à
gauche et pas de conservateur à droite
bien que les conservateurs soient comme
clairement plus à droite que tu es à
gauche là conservateur c'est vraiment un
nouveau parti qui propose quand même des
propositions qui sont très différentes
des autres dans le système politique
québécois et toi le PQ qui est
clairement de centre gauche et les
libéraux on en parlera qui n'ont pas
vraiment de direction en ce moment c'est
pas très clair leur gouvernance sous
couleur était plutôt à droite là il
semble essayer de se positionner un peu
plus au centre mais c'est pas très clair
ou est-ce que ça s'en va la cake m'a
ensuite c'est que la gauche et la droite
il y a deux gauches puis deux droites en
fait il y a la gauche de la droite en
termes de tu veux tu plus de dépenses
publiques plus de taxes ou moins ça
c'est la gauche droite traditionnelle
mais aussi une autre un autre axe qui
est à quel point tes
identitaires tu veux moins d'immigration
tu n'aimes pas trop la mondialisation et
tu as une conception un peu plus
traditionnelle des valeurs sociales par
exemple sur le mot sexualité les
pratiques sexuelles différentes
etc
ou
et donc sur cet axe là la CAQ c'est
positionné plus conservatrice un peu
plus valeur traditionnelle moins
d'immigration défense de la société
traditionnelle si on peut mais sur l'axe
dépense publique la CAQ est plutôt
centrée franchement et c'est ça qu'ils
veulent vous présenter ils veulent dire
nous on est entre les deux extrêmes et
essayer de marginaliser le pqlq c'est ça
la stratégie de la CAQ mais donc on peut
les positionner
de cette manière là ce sens où le PLQ et
centré sur la question état dépense plus
ou moins plus ou moins de dépenses et
plutôt en faveur de l'immigration etc
sur l'autre axe
QS est à gauche sur les deux et le PQ
relativement à gauche sur la dépense
publique un peu plus traditionaliste sur
l'autre sur l'autre axe
mettons qu'on parle
mettons qu'on parle d'immigration qui
est un thème
bien exploré dans les débats puis les
la conversation le dialogue public en ce
moment qu'est-ce que les parties
proposent puis juste un petit survol
rapidement peut-être qu'on peut rentrer
plus en détail qu'est-ce qui est
faisable ou qu'est-ce qui est possible
donc je peux un spécialiste de
l'immigration mais ce que je comprends
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de débats sur
les seuils d'immigration qui sont pas
des débats qui ont beaucoup de sens
parce que il y a quand même une grande
grande proportion des personnes qui
immigrent au Québec sans nécessairement
y rester qui sont des
découvert temporaire ou des gens sont en
permis Vacances Travail ou des étudiants
donc quand on parle de seuil
d'immigration c'est comme on ne parle
pas ces gens-là on parle de seuil de
personnes qui deviennent des résidents
vivre ici et des futurs citoyens mais tu
peux rester pas mal longtemps là
étudiant ou en permis de travail etc
donc
c'est là que c'est difficile à comparer
est-ce que est-ce que US propose un
nombre plus élevé de migrants permanents
à 60 60 à 80000 les libéraux je pense à
60 70
le diminuer à 35 mais ensuite si
QS a dans sa tête l'idée que ben c'est
70 permanent mais on compte les
étudiants ça revient au même pas mal que
ce que la CAQ propose le donc ces
chiffres-là me semblent un peu c'est un
peu vraiment impositionnement que les
parties c'est de montrer en plus ou
moins ouvert sur l'immigration je pense
que finalement chef veut pas dire grand
chose je pense que le chevalier mais
comment est utilisé
les c'est quoi qui propose les parties
pour l'intégration en termes de budget
est-ce que c'est budgété ça ouais benqs
un gros budget intégration là c'est sûr
qu'ils en ont le plus définitivement
si j'avais bien ici ça c'est les revenus
euh tu vois c'est quelque chose comme
600 millions de dépenses de dollars en
intégration c'est assez ben la liste est
tellement longue de la promesse un peu
de le voir mais bref
du côté de la CAQ par contre il y a pas
beaucoup de dépenses sur avant c'était
le grand si on en prend moins mon en
prend soin il y a pas beaucoup de
dépenses supplémentaires en intégration
des immigrants alors que tant QS PLK a
des dépenses supplémentaires parce que
bon il semble y avoir un enjeu d'accès
au cours de francisation ce qui semble
être quand même un problème sérieux
aussi je pense qu'il y a l'idée de faut
compenser financièrement les gens qui
vont faire les cours de francisation si
c'est un cours intensif par exemple tu
peux pas travailler mais ça sera le fun
que que l'état donne quelque chose donc
c'est ça les coûts c'est ça c'est juste
logique dans le fond que ceux qui qui se
positionnent comme étant ceux qui sont
le plus en faveur d'immigration soit
ceux qui investissent également le plus
dans l'intégration mais c'est pas les
dépenses très très élevées de
l'intégration des immigrants c'est pas
tant de monde comme ça puis c'est pas
très tellement dépense de dépenses par
personne parce qu'il y en a qui vont qui
en ont pas besoin il y a pas tous les
immigrants qui vont aller chercher une
dépense publique
pitié faut l'immigration c'est pas
quelque chose qui coûte le au Québec là
c'est pas c'est pas dans la catégorie
des dépenses non c'est ça mais même au
contraire finalement parce que en ce
moment on a un problème de pénurie de
main d'oeuvre qu'on a besoin de monde
qui travaille et ça il y a un débat
là-dessus il y en a beaucoup qui disent
que l'immigration ça règle pas la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre parce que Ben
chaque nouvelle personne aussi besoin de
service public donc le gain est faible à
moins de vraiment changer la structure
démographique mais c'est pas
nécessairement le cas parce que il y a
quand même la réunification familiale
donc une personne qui arrive ici à 30-40
ans on va peut-être faire venir ses
parents donc on a pas réglé le problème
de pénurie de main d'oeuvre et
l'immigration ça fait croître la taille
totale de l'économie ça c'est sûr mais
ça fait pas il y a pas de lien direct
entre ça rend les gens plus riches par
habitant OK
puis c'est la pénurie de élèves l'ego va
pas tard dans le sens où c'est pas
nécessairement bon pour le total de
l'économie québécoise mais c'est bon
pour les employés parce qu'ils vont ils
valent plus cher il y en a moins de
bâton oui et puis on le voit la hausse
des salaires et au Québec
les gens gagnent plus d'argent qu'avant
et c'est donc ça c'était fait la pénurie
de main d'oeuvre c'est pas pour rien que
les employeurs veulent
résoudre la pénurie de main d'oeuvre en
important plus de monde parce que si tu
fais juste regarder une coupe d’œuf et
de demande sur le travail ben ça fait
que tu as plus d'oeufs de travail fait
que ça coûte moins cher le travail donc
l'employeur est content ça c'est sûr que
ça fait ça ensuite
on peut se dire tu as besoin de plus de
monde dans certains secteurs de pointe
qui vont vraiment rendre l'économie plus
productive ça je crois cet argument là
aussi
comme lesquels
l'intelligence artificielle il y a pas
assez de monde un ingénieur informatique
il y en a pas assez
on a des amis qui ont qui sont retournés
à l'école que changement de carrière
complet qui ont commencé à faire un bac
en informatique en informatique puis là
c'est des acides de job à sortir de
l'école c'est ça puis il y a pas
beaucoup de compétitions donc ça a rien
enlever à vos amis c'est que c'est
avec eux donc c'est sûr que tu as une
grosse job donc et aussi bon ensuite
c'est effectivement il y a plein de
secteurs autre que que qui sont moins
populaires puis qui a besoin de monde là
donc ça c'est j'accepte ça argument là
mettez je pense qu'il faut pas accepter
l'idée que l'immigration est une
solution 100% certaine main d'oeuvre je
pense que beaucoup d'incertitude puis le
goût dit c'est une bonne affaire
qu'est-ce que les autres disent par
rapport les autres ce qui proposent des
solutions on appelle une main vous oui
mais justement c'est qu'il y a d'autres
solutions si tu peux essayer d'investir
davantage dans dans favoriser
l'innovation dans les entreprises parce
que l'idée de la pénurie de manœuvre tu
peux la régler aussi en rendant les gens
plus productifs c'est-à-dire par exemple
si ton entreprise achète plus de
machines mettons d'automat
automatisation réduire le besoin de main
d'oeuvre s'assurer que les gens se
concentrent sur des secteurs plus
productifs ou des parties plus
productives de l'entreprise c'est un peu
l'objectif au Québec terre
traditionnellement les entreprises
investissent pas beaucoup dans ce type
de d'innovation là parce qu'on a
toujours une main d'oeuvre relativement
chips
autre solution et c'est probable et tous
les partis s'entendent là-dessus c'est
assez intéressant c'est la seule chose
que tous les partis proposent donc c'est
à peu près certain qu'on va dans cette
direction là c'est que au Québec il y a
des choses qu'on fait bien par rapport à
la participation au marché du travail
par exemple on a la meilleure
participation des femmes au marché du
travail du Canada et de l'Amérique du
Nord ça c'est excellent ça c'est il y a
la plus petite différence homme et femme
dans la participation du marché au
marché du travail ça c'est bien c'est
grâce au service de garde c'est grâce
aux bonnes politiques familiales et je
dirais c'est aussi grâce à une norme
relativement forte d'égalité des gens
mais ce qu'on observe c'est que une
catégorie de la population travaille
considérablement moins que d'autres
c'est les personnes de 55 ans et plus
que ce qui travaille considérablement
moins que les personnes de 55 quand même
plus en Ontario par exemple donc une des
réponses à la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
c'est de s'assurer que ces gens-là
travaillent plus et pour ce faire elle
est partie vont proposer toutes sortes
d'institatifs fiscaux ce que en ce
moment il y a quand même plusieurs
personnes qui vont qui ont pas beaucoup
d'initatives à aller travailler parce
qu'ils vont par exemple perdre des
prestations de retraite en allant
travailler etc donc à peu près tous les
parties proposent différentes mesures
qui visent à comme donner un petit boost
aux personnes de 60 ans qui décident de
rester sur le marché du travail pour les
inciter à rester sur le marché du
travail sont assez chanceux parce qu'ils
vont se faire donner du cache pour
rester à l'emploi alors que vous vous ne
faites pas de nez de cash pour rester à
l’endroit mais en même temps vous
travaillez quand même et eux non donc
c'est un peu gros bout du bâton de la
négociation mais ça c'est une bonne
solution à la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
en fait on peut quasiment la régler si
leur taux d'emploi rejoint
canadien
la moyenne
par rapport à la moyenne canadienne
c'est la participation des femmes en
général on la participation des plus
vieux et les plus faible et ça ça crée
plus de pénurie de main d'oeuvre donc
c'est une des solutions tous les parties
proposent assez intéressant il y a
vraiment consensus il y a différentes
manières de procéder là mais attendez
vous est-ce que dans les prochains
budget ça soit quelque chose qui soit
beaucoup mis de l'avance déjà la carte a
déjà commencé à travailler quand même
pas mal là-dessus depuis ces quatre
budgets
encore les booms encore les bouts
travailler les boomers
mais nous on prendra jamais notre
retraite à 55 ans
dans 2 minutes puis je suis
suis loin d'avoir pris ma retraite je
suis en train de payer mes dettes
d'études encore là
c'est pas fini
on parle tout de santé ouais parlons de
santé parce que ça c'est l'enfant ça
dépend ce miroir j'imagine parce que là
on parle à boomers
de la population donc
la santé c'est un on appelle un valent
échou c'est à dire tout le monde est
d'accord pour dépenser plus sauf les
conservateurs même là la seule dépense
que les conservateurs proposent de plus
c'est des polices puis des infirmières
dépensent supplémentaires les
conservateurs proposent puis parce que
tout le monde aime ça les infirmières
plusieurs personnes aiment ça les
polices donc ça c'est donc tout le monde
s'entende pour dire que il faut comme
aider le réseau de la santé ensuite
parlons des conservateurs eux ils vont
dire privatisant davantage
et
ça peut être une solution puis ça c'est
ça à peu près tous les partis tous les
autres partis sont conçus
cela dit la CAQ en fait la même promesse
en 2018
je fais travailler sur un livre
d'ailleurs le bilan du des promesses du
gouvernement logo qui est en librairie à
Lille vous le procurer si ça vous
intéresse qui monte en fait ben la
promesse en santé sur le privé tel les
mêmes à peu près en 2018 il y a des
petits détails mais il proposait plus de
place au privé et on parle ici de privé
en santé on parle de la prestation de
service on parle pas du financement ces
deux choses en ce sens où tu pourrais
avoir des hôpitaux 100% privés qui sont
remboursés par le réseau public c'est
différent de dire bah tu dois avoir une
assurance privée pour aller à un hôpital
privé c'est très très différent parce
que dans le fond c'est ton hôpital privé
payé par le public ben ça demande les
impôts qu'ils payent les plus pauvres
ils ont quand même accès et en ce moment
mes médecins sont des prestataires
privés sont payés par le public mais les
médecins c'est quand que tu travailles
quand un médecin une clinique c'est une
clinique privée c'est ça business
donc c'est moins que le dire on va
privatiser le financement ce que la pcq
propose mais si tu proposes plus
d'assurance privée dans le fond tu
pourrais avoir une assurance privée qui
permettrait à aller dans un hôtel moyen
exactement
mais l'hôpital est quand même financé
par l'État je pense que eux ils veulent
genre idéalement dans le monde parce
qu'on s'avatateur il y aurait des
hôpitaux privés qui serviraient qui sont
qui sont affiliés à des assurances
privées comme aux États-Unis aux
États-Unis tu as des hôpitaux privés qui
affiliés aux assurances
pour te banquer ok ok
des équipements puis ensuite tu donnes
les services à des gens qui sont assurés
ok le dans leur proposition que je vois
sur me trompe il y a aussi de simplifier
la
la transition des médecins entre les
deux systèmes
soit au public qui qui a plus de place
pour opérer à cause des des
attentes ces affaires-là peut facilement
changer dans le système privé ça c'est
ça c'est un grand mythe que c'est l'idée
que en ayant un système privé ça va
régler des problèmes d'accès au système
c'est un mythe complet parce que c'est
les mêmes employés il y a pas de il y a
pas d'employés là qui attendent chez eux
c'est ton épouse il y a peut-être des
anecdotes il y a pas de monde qui
attendent chez eux cette année pouce et
qui peuvent pas travailler c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche il y en a
peut-être quelques-uns c'est arrivé
pendant la pandémie parce que il y avait
des
salopération qui est fermée mais
on s'enfermés parce que tout le monde
est occupés
mais donc
si c'est un mythe que le réseau privé
règles des problèmes de pénurie de main
d'oeuvre dans le total parce que le
problème il les attendent des problèmes
des délais plus probable si tu vois
l'urgence ça prend 14 heures c'est qu'il
manque de moi c'est ça c'est ça
finalement
des problèmes en ce sens où tu sais
c'est qu'il y a des attentes à l'urgence
pas parce que nos urgences sont pas
efficaces mais parce que il passe il y a
trop de monde qui vont l'urgence au lieu
d'aller à la première ligne qui serait
par exemple un CLSC c'est là que par
exemple QS et le PQ propose de remettre
de l'avant l'idée des CLSC qui était
quand même vraiment une idée plutôt cool
et innovatrice du Québec le steak comme
une idée spéciale au Québec qui avait
pas ailleurs au Canada qui est l'idée
que mais tu as des centres ou de
plusieurs
professionnels de la santé pas juste des
médecins pas juste des infirmières il y
a des travailleurs sociales aussi des
psychologues même des physiothérapeutes
qui s'occupent de la première ligne donc
des des bobos soignables dans une
clinique que tu as pas besoin de
meilleurs équipement à l'hôpital parce
que là nous hôpitaux quand un cancer au
Québec ça bobe mais c'est pas le fan de
boire un cancer mais on a les
traitements
de la pointe elle est solide c'est
l'accès
infirmière à Saint-Pierre
les gens peuvent pas se le permettre
donc il y a des gens qui sont pas
vraiment en grande paire d'autonomie qui
se ramassent dans le réseau CHSLD ça ça
coûte quand même relativement pas mal
cher à l'État donc c'est une manière de
rendre le système plus efficace
puisse la proposition du PQ c'est les
plus ambitieux par rapport au service
très important à domicile le PQ vraiment
moi je trouve c'est un programme
intéressant parce que il est vraiment
clair tu es essaie de changer le monde
c'est pas le mauvais choix d'essayer de
changer le monde il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de promesses par contre tactile
c'est comme ça va être top à faire là on
va on va revenir vers plus tard dans le
podcast sur comme la faisabilité toutes
les promesses qu'on parle en ce moment
mais justement en PQ ce que j'aime c'est
que il y a trois grosses promesses ils
disent CPE là il y en a plus de garderie
privée on finit le réseau des CPE on met
750 millions là-dedans Go soit un
domicile les personnes âgées mais 3
milliards par année donc c'est le de
loin le plus gros la plus grosse dépense
une idée de grandeur la CAQ propose
de millions en soins à domicile de plus
là
une coupe de santé
donc et un autre milliard en logement
social ça c'est le PQ vous disent ben
voici les trois gros trucs je pense
c'est pertinent c'est à dire c'est quoi
les trois gros problèmes qu'on veut
régler comme des fils un gouvernement il
y a des limites au nombre de choses qui
peut faire c'est réglé trois problèmes
moi je trouve ça pas pire dans le fond
si on reprend ce que tu viens de dire il
règle le problème ils veulent régler le
problème le le la crise du logement
crise du logement le problème des soins
admissibles pour les personnes âgées
pour payer des problèmes de réseau de la
santé puis les CPE il y a quand même
payé un investissement conséquent dans
les CLSI donc si on parle de réseau de
santé pour terminer là-dessus je pense
que tout le monde a des promesses
précédents la première ligne puis la CAC
a quand même proposé un document qui est
plein de bonnes idées l'année dernière
ils ont dit mon voici plein de réformes
qu'on préfère dans le réseau de la santé
c'est toujours plus facile à dire qu'à
faire un réseau de la santé par contre
le site complexes à réformé il y a comme
c'est gros là c'est beaucoup de monde
mais moi je dirais simplement le mirage
du privé faites attention c'est pas
avec ça qu'on va régler le problème là
moi cette proposition là mettons je me
discrim si ceux qui ont les moyens de
payer mettons vont briver ça fait que
moins de monde au public ça fait que le
monde qui ont moins les moyens d'aller
au public vont là ça va plus vite tout
le monde est content mais finalement
c'est pas ça prend toutes mais ça serait
ça si ça n'a rien des médecins
le problème c'est qu'il y a un supply il
y a une offre limitée donc ton employé
il peut pas être dédoublé puis c'est pas
vrai que
vont travailler plus parce qu'il y a une
possibilité de faire de l'argent privé
ce qu'on observe les médecins sont
tellement payés cher que tu peux pas les
faire travailler plus il gagne déjà
assez d'argent ils vont pas être ils
vont pas vouloir travailler à
l'intérieur de plus parce qu'ils sont
déjà ces pays j'ai comprendre mais dans
le plan du Parti conservateur il y a pas
non plus augmenter les seuils d'entrée
dans les programmes de médecine
justement pour être capable de fournir
ce système là ouais mais c'est il y a
pas le coup de ça non c'est ça
exactement
ensuite
la CAQ a décidé d'arrêter de dire qu'il
s'attaquer au médecin parce qu'ils ont
essayé de le faire la dernière fois que
ça peut fonctionner le PQ etqs ça dans
leur programme de diminuer la
rémunération des médecins la PQ deux
manières vraiment conséquente là ils
sont optimistes dans ce qu'ils sont
capables de faire mais ça c'est un des
enjeux du système
terminant la discussion sur le système
de santé deux enjeux médecins sont
vraiment payés cher ça draine des
ressources là c'est évident mais si je
peux faire un petit tutoriel là-dessus
parce qu'elle m'a payé cher mais
particulièrement certaines spécialités
qui sont payées ridiculement cher versus
des médecins de famille puis des
médecins de famille c'est ça
que tout le monde sait qu'on cherche
les gens ont besoin
des spécialités qui vont faire 4,5 mois
plus que c'est salaire là il me semble
que Ben pas 4 5 fois les médecins de
famille gagnent quand même facile deux
250 300000 les spécialités qui sont
800000 ouais mais ça c'est rare quand
même c'est plus autour de 500 mais cinq
sens beaucoup mais oui c'est puis mais
même tous les médecins sont dans 1%
s'ils travaillent plus que le temple que
tu en passant
considéré là je voudrais faire une étude
qui démontre que c'est difficile de
faire une politique qui augmente plus
les revenus de 1% que d'augmenter le
salaire des médecins au Québec
c'est ça c'est que les médecins ils
contrôlent le système hospitalier il
fait que si ils veulent pas travailler
ils font ils peuvent pas exactement
faire la grève mais ils peuvent comme
disons faire la grève du zèle et ça mais
c'est très négatif puis il y a quand
même une crédibilité dans la population
donc c'est très dur de s'y attaquer
c'est probablement le groupe d'intérêt
le plus fort au Québec c'est complexe
aussi parce que tu mettons le justement
un médecin en fin de carrière mais cette
famille en fin de carrière en
pré-retraite qui dit en moi je vois
diminuer ma pratique mettons je prends
moins une patient mais je continue
encore un peu une coupe d’année puis
commencer à je sais pas le jardiner plus
mais là c'est comme maintenant il faut
que vous travaillez on vous impose un
quota
travaille juste pour lui d'avoir du
monde qui travaille à moitié on a du
monde travaille pas partout parce qu'on
les moyens de prendre la retraite taxi
c'est c'est c'est pas si simple que ça
non plus leur dire juste travailler avec
ce moment
pour pour les faire travailler plus mais
faut revoir la rémunération puis il faut
qu'il gagne moins d'argent il y a pas
vraiment si c'est juste bien
plus que le premier ministre
ça pas vraiment sens puis si gagne plus
que le premier ministre parce qu'ils ont
été en mesure d'extraire une rente c'est
un groupe d'intérêt qui est extraire du
dos des taxes c'est ça que c'est là il
gagne même moyen en Europe dans la
plupart des pays puis à ce niveau-là
est-ce que tous les partis s'entendent
que pour diminuer le salaire des
médecins et j'imagine que les parties
conservatoire non
pas beaucoup de détails dans leur
programme là donc c'est plus difficile à
dire
les libéraux sont dans pas parce qu'on
mal placé pour parler parce qu'ils l'ont
augmenté en maudit
dans le temps où est-ce que le ministère
c'est n'était que des médecins ministres
de l'éducation c'est un cardiaque je
pense que en fait PQ oui et la claque
ben je pense que c'est parce qu'il le
remettent pas dans leur programme parce
qu'ils ont essayé puis ils savent que
c'est difficile c'est que je pense que
c'est ça euh ça sera pas ça sera pas
simple l'autre enjeu système de santé
qui est intéressant c'est la couverture
de ce qui est pas couvert parce que on
oublie le mais on a un système de santé
qui est très privatisé en fait en ce
sens où il y a beaucoup de services de
santé puisque le jentaire optique
physiothérapie soins indemnistes pour
les personnes âgées qui ne sont presque
pas couverts par le réseau public même
médicament on a une assurance médicament
au Québec mais c'est une assurance
complémentaire c'est à dire que dès que
vous avez une assurance privée vous êtes
hors de l'assurance médicament public
donc c'est pas la plupart des pays ont
une assurance médicament publique qui
couvre à peu près l'ensemble tout le
monde est couvert
les pays qui ont un système de santé
universel ensuite bon il y a QS qui
propose vraiment comme quelque chose qui
ressemble à une assurance dentaire
universelle ouais ensuite le PQ il va un
peu plus
brise duel c'est-à-dire on augmente la
couverture actuelle parce qu'en ce
moment certaines catégories de la
population y ont accès c'est vraiment
plus comme personnage et enfants et
personne plutôt donc c'est ça c'est
quelque chose qui peut avoir un impact
sur le système de santé en général par
exemple soit psychologique si on avait
plus accès à ça potentiellement à moyen
terme les gens sont moins malades parce
que ta santé psychologique se traduit un
jour par une des problèmes
physiologiques et ça c'est assez
intéressant que finalement la partie qui
est le plus généreux pour la santé
mentale c'est le Parti libéral du Québec
ceux qui ont la dépense la plus élevée
qui est prévue ils veulent proposer
10 séances par année de soins
psychologiques
tout le monde qui en aurait besoin je
sais pas faudrait que quelqu'un qui
connaît vraiment ce domaine-là en
particulier définissent 450 millions
c'est suffisant pour ça
mais c'est du moins plus que tous les
autres c'est plus que toutes les autres
parties donc ça veut dire que c'est eux
qui ont qui c'est plus conséquent de ce
que j'ai vu à vérifier aussi veut
proposer ça mais un budget un petit peu
moins puis le PQ aussi budget un petit
peu moins là-dessus la CAC on a aussi un
budget est un petit peu moins aussi donc
tout le monde veut plus de soins
psychologiques que tout le monde sait
que c'est important mais personne
propose quelque chose qui serait
vraiment universel sauf peut-être la
partie libérale qui semble aller vers
cette direction là puis ça à mon avis
moi je prioriserais ça plus que le
dentaire en ce sens où il fédéral veut
le faire le dentaire fait que bon il y a
moyen
ça c'est une autre histoire mais ça
c'est le fédéralisme on en parlera une
autre fois puis mais c'est aussi la
santé mentale j'ai l'impression que
c'est que ça a tellement d'impact sur
l'ensemble de la santé que les dents
aussi là mais comme moi c'est comme ta
santé mentale ce serait bien d'avoir des
investissements supplémentaires
là-dessus bon ensuite il y a des
pénuries psychologues ça c'est le
problème c'est là que c'est vrai que bon
les pénuries sont à régler
il y en a dans le public c'est juste pas
beaucoup il y a la possibilité si tu
veux avoir un rendez-vous dans le public
va attendre en Moody là c'est ça le
problème tu peux en avoir mais ça va
être vraiment long déjà que dans le
privé tu attends quand même pas mal
maintenant parce que la pandémie a été
dure
pour la santé
transitionnons vers l'environnement qui
est on n'arrête pas de se faire dire que
c'est encore une fois c'est mon
algorithme j'imagine que quelqu'un qui
qui l’algorithme iriduel m'entend moins
parler de ça mais on a entendu que c'est
l'élection de l'environnement puis on a
on le sent on le sent partout dans le
monde on sent que c'est l'urgence
climatique qui est au cœur de tous un
jeu tout le monde propose des solutions
mais la question c'est à quel niveau à
quel niveau d'implication puis qu'est-ce
que ça représente on peut peut-être
partir dans le fond par le gouvernement
en sortant laque qu'est-ce qui propose
la carte exactement à ce niveau-là
ma question comme continuer à ma tête
pendant que j'ai arrêté de parler mais
tantôt tu disais tu es qui a plusieurs
grosses gros enjeux à un budget mais que
l'environnement devenait un enjeu
massif qui qui va falloir s'occuper de
juste voir à quel point les parties
ajoute ça c'est des dépenses existantes
environnement
pour leur faire parce que tu regardes
dans les dépenses prévues
il n'y en a pas un environnement il y en
a pas davantage non et il n'y a pas
davantage à dépenses prévues en
environnement dans le programme que
celles qui sont déjà en place que les
choses qui ont déjà mis en place les
journalistes n'ont pas dit beaucoup mais
quand tu regardes ces ganson ce qui est
cool en ce moment au Québec c'est que il
y a un rapport prélevable qui a été
vérifié qui a été produit par le
ministre des Finances qui dit voici ce
qu'on s'attend combien coûter les trucs
dans les prochaines années et la
vérification générale qui est une
comptable indépendante de Chucky puis a
dit c'est vrai donc ça c'est intéressant
toutes les parties se base là-dessus
pour faire leur promesse
dans ce rapport il y a vraiment pas de
croissance et dépenses en environnement
donc il y a même une baisse à un moment
donné parce qu'il y a des programmes qui
finissent donc ce que la carte nous dit
continuons
c'est assez impressionnant par rapport à
tous les autres partis c'est le
programme que c'est vraiment continuer
il y a pas
il y a pas de nouveaux trucs
la plus grosse dépense de la CAQ c'est
mon temps de soutien aux aînés parce
qu'ils se disent le problème de la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre causée par les
personnes plus âgées qui travaillent pas
suffisamment un point 5 milliards mais à
part de ça c'est des
services de la dette
c'est des petites dépenses des deux 200
millions on continue en tout cas nous
propose en gros c'est on va dépenser un
peu pour que les gens travaillent plus
qui sont un peu plus âgés et on va
baisser vos impôts sinon vous avez aimé
notre gouvernement nous continuons donc
sur l'environnement on change pas d'air
mais François Legault et j'aime que
aucune dépense il y en a pas vraiment
dans le budget en ce moment-là il y a
pas de problème
prévu dans les prochaines années et il
n'en propose pas davantage mettons qu'on
est ils n'ont pas dit non plus parce que
tu peux faire des mesures
environnementales qui n'impliquent pas
de dépenses par exemple tu peux dire on
va augmenter la taxe carbone on en a une
autre ici
exactement
[Musique]
la retraite en un
oiseau qui existe à la planète il s'est
quand même passé des affaires au niveau
environnemental d'un cadre de la
dernière année là c'est des des alarmes
qui ont commencé à
sonner plus forte que il se lève par
exemple les villes ont demandé à le goût
de d'avoir 2 milliards par année en
dépense d'infrastructures pour s'adapter
au changement climatique il y a dit non
le lendemain il y a une inondation à
Montréal où moi j'avais jamais vu ça
personnellement là j'ai peut-être oublié
le mais c'est des rues non des de même
j'ai vu ça Bangkok le mais pas ici
donc bon on aurait dit ouais c'est ça
donc là
mais c'est pas dans leur programme donc
François degault c'est pas oui c'est il
y a des problèmes mais
c'est que peut-être que le goût a une
relation un peu cynique avec cette
situation là c'est à dire que
va faire pas d'impact c'est juste que à
un moment donné ça manque d'éthique il
faut quand même réfléchir à si tout le
monde faisait comme nous mais ça irait
bien ou ça irait mal et ça irait mal si
tout le monde faisait comme nous parce
qu'on est des polluants épouvantables
mais reste que
c'est ça
mais François Legault il arrête pas de
se vanter quel Québec on est les
meilleurs en Amérique du Nord comme on
est les meilleurs juste parce qu'on a
déro l'électricité tu sais c'est comme
honnêtement là c'est un fait que entre
les promesses canadiennes il y a des
niveaux de pollution tellement
différents c'est tout à fait expliqué
par à quel point tu vois
l'hydroélectricité ou du pétrole puis si
on est naval pétrole puis l'alberto à
villedroélectricité on serait exactement
l'inverse ignoré d'avoir des rivières
puis il y a aucune différence parce que
ça c'est l'autre à faire sur
l'environnement
je pense qu'il y a de plus en plus de
gens qui ont commencé à être prêtes à
faire des sacrifices mais je pense que
la CAQ savent très bien que les gens ils
disent qu'ils veulent sauver
l'environnement mais si tu leur dis ok
mais il faut que tu aies une taxe
carbone à 200$ la tonne ça veut dire une
augmentation du prix de l'essence de 45
donc personne veut ça quand tu leur dis
ben ok mais il faut que tes shorts tu
les payes
5000 pièces de plus si pollue plus que
la moyenne ma personne veut ça fait que
il faudrait qu'on ait une taxe
kilométrique pour empêcher l'étalement
urbain mais personne ne veut ça et c'est
toujours ça tu sais c'est dès qu'il y a
des coûts les gens veulent pas payer
pour l'environnement parce que c'est
vrai que ça donne pas des bénéfices
immédiats les trucs qu'on fait pour
l'environnement c'est pour sauver la
planète dans 30 ans c'est quand même
bientôt planète
de de vérité comme un rond là mais ça
c'est mais moi c'est le but ou au début
les misérables c'est misérables
pour les promesses bon au moins la carte
fait pas pire que parce qu'on va faire
vraiment c'est un peu drôle mon
électorat ils veulent rien savoir de
l'environnement il trouve que c'est
assumer que je veux les hydrocarbures là
il faut même enlever les subventions
véhicule électrique
c'est un peu c'est un peu comics
oui c'est en ligne il y en a pas de
problème
il était génial Québec etc sont puis là
moi je fais vraiment l'avocat du diable
sont son point étant
que notre impact au Québec est minime
ton changement personnel au pôle impact
donc c'est ensuite comment tu peux
dans des rencontres internationales
c'était le Canada puis tout est
provinces font rien tu veux te montrer
un exemple aussi mais ensuite tu peux
pousser les autres vers aller plus loin
et puis ensuite faut aussi penser un peu
à l'avenir l'Europe sont quand même
vraiment en avance puis abandonner là ça
va arriver que tu crois plus faire de
t'auras plus d'accès au libre-échange si
tu auras pas des normes
environnementales plus élevées
ça va donner un avantage compétitif un
jour ça c'est important à long terme
puis c'est une vision c'est une vision
quand même fermée de pas voir ça je
pense que à un moment donné il va avoir
comme des acteurs internationaux
importants comme Union européenne ou
même peut-être les États-Unis sous les
présidents démocrates qui vont faire des
trucs du genre si vous vous êtes des
cancres en environnement vous avez des
conséquences
ça ça va être à c'est sûr que ça arrive
un jour
j'ai mode depuis que j'étais en âge de
voter
c'était pas mal la première fois que
j'entendais un chef de partie
dire
publiquement puis je parle de Gabriel
dans du bois de dire publiquement moi je
vais être à naître il y a des sacrifices
qu'il faut qu'on fasse de le dire de le
dire comme ça ouvertement moi de toutes
les campagnes électorales que j'ai fait
c'était pas mal la première fois que
quelqu'un allait nous regarder en disant
là les habitudes individuelles va
falloir que ça change tu sais puis c'est
quoi qui propose qu'avec solidaire d'un
point de vue de comme de de lui appelle
pas ça il refuse d'appeler ça des
sacrifices là mais c'est pas mal des
changements de de mode de vie maintenant
le premier truc qui implique un
sacrifice c'est la taxation des voitures
polluantes ça ça à mon avis ça tout à
fait du sens parce que juste donner de
l'argent pour s'acheter des véhicules
électriques ça coûte quand même ça coûte
quand même cher les tests à faire là
idéalement on financerait c'est
subventions là par les consommateurs de
voitures plus énergivore tu pourrais le
faire à peu près équivalent si le monde
achète moins de chars énergivore
ça veut dire que ton objectif est
atteindre et si le monde en achète plus
avec une énergie va ben c'est pas donné
plus de subventions électriques ça
pourrait être un programme à peu près à
coup nul moi j'aimerais savoir ça
personnellement et donc ils veulent
taxer les voitures plus polluantes il y
a hier on parlait de ces promesses et
puis
ça ça paraît effectivement comme une
super bonne idée mais après ce type
mettons dans le débat le goût disait
donc mettons les familles ou ceux qui en
région qui ont besoin non non mais les
familles vont être exemptées puis aussi
dépendamment où tu habites ça va être
modulaire de ton travail puis on dirait
que ça m'a parlé une logistique
bureaucratique aucun sens là finalement
moi je pense qu'il faut y aller plus
encaisseur
quand même gros qui consomme pas tant
que ça mais oui
tu peux avoir toutes les chars
électriques mais aussi c'est juste mais
achète pas pick-up consommateur ou il y
en a des Vans consomme moins que
d'autres en tout cas
c'est ça
puis bon il y a des taxes sur les gros
pollueurs que QS proposent évidemment
mais ça c'est souvent c'est de dire les
compagnies
l'affaire c'est que c'est facile de dire
ça
mais c'est parce que
les prix au consommateurs donc c'est que
les gens comprennent pas que les tags
sur les gros pollueurs ça implique des
prix plus élevés mais
me semble que c'est pas juste le
président qui va réduire son salaire
pour non payer les taxes c'est rarement
comme ça fonctionne c'est sûr que non
en gros c'est que tant que est-ce que le
PQ propose vraiment des investissements
massifs en transport en commun et ça je
pense que ça ça a beaucoup de sens tu
sais c'est ce qu'on doit c'est ce qu'on
doit viser franchement bon il y a
Peillon différents noms la révolution
transport etc quand même l'idée de
transport en commun vraiment pas cher
avec une espèce de passe annuelle qui
peut être peuvent être intéressants et
c'est vrai que
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal de s'active
les trucs faciles à faire en
environnement et facile c'est plus de
transport en commun et favoriser
l'économie d'énergie des maisons pour
construire moins de barrage pour
électrifier les transports par exemple
donc c'est pas des c'est pas si
compliqué c'est sûr que oui dit qu'il
faut faire des sacrifices mais j'ai pas
vu c'est que idéalement faudrait que la
taxe carbone soit vraiment plus élevée
ça c'est ça le sacrifice à faire
c'est il faut que l'essence coûte plus
cher
c'est intéressant de le voir parce que
là on a eu on a eu une expérience là
dessus l'essence a vraiment augmenter
puis là c'est la panique là
même PQ il faut qu'on trouve une manière
d'aller chercher les profits des
messages entreprises pour baisser les
prix c'est
c'est ça c'est on voit que c'est pas
facile là c'est sûr que le monde se dise
ah mais non on paye plus cher pour
l'essence pas pour l'environnement là
c'est juste de même mais les
comportements sont longs à changer et
puis si pas il y a pas il y a pas 36
solutions
qui mettait en cause la pandémie des
concessionnaires sont pas capables de
fournir mais genre les attendre en deux
ans pour avoir deux ans le monde ça a
monté en route deux pièces puis le monde
se sont car rocher acheter le sort
électrique c'est pas c'est pas non plus
compliqué à voir le lien
si c'était plus cher le monde achèterait
plus de champ électrique point final
mais il y a aussi il y a aussi la
densification urbaine qui est importante
puis ça c'est ben c'est la banlieue
coûte pas cher c'est quand tu regardes
de la dépense publique par habitant de
banlieue versus de ville le banlieusard
reçois tellement plus de valeur de
service public parce que il coûte plus
cher les services publics parce qu'ils
sont pas densifiés création de route
création des goûts etc
ils sont au niveau taxation est
tellement plus bas à sa maison moins
cher et les taxes sont plus faibles que
c'est inégal et l'externalité écologique
est immense parce que tu vas prendre
plus ton short parce que tu détruis des
milieux naturels
il faut changer ça c'est juste qu'on a
l'idée que tout le monde doit avoir
droit à sa maison une famille familiale
ça c'est le sacrifice c'est aussi mais
ça aucun policier va vous le dire parce
que ça commence à être mais c'est pas
juste ça c'est aussi que c'est tellement
cher acheter à Montréal versus acheter
en région le monde vont vont préférer
les installer à une heure et quart de
Montréal puis quand même aller à un jour
à Montréal travailler mais ça aussi
parce qu'on a décidé qu'il fallait qu'on
soit propriétaire d'une maison une
familiale
c'est
peut-être un modèle à revoir
malheureusement et c'est là que ça tu
vois c'est ça puis je comprends qu'il y
a aucun parti qui en parle parce que tu
m'en parles puis ça me crée de l'anxiété
seul il est pas le fun il y en a plein
qui sont acceptables et qui sont comme
c'est le transport en commun ça fait du
sens
c'est de l'argent avec les hommes mène à
quelque chose
mais même si cher électrique c'est juste
comme tu pensais que non plus mais même
si l'essence coûte plus cher tu sais je
comprends aussi puis mais celle-là est
offé parce que en même temps que ça
allait vraiment top il y a comme une
maison vraiment et comme genre de
dichotomie entre
moi je me considère environnementaliste
je le disais hier moi je suis vegan pour
l'environnement puis je prends mes
décisions quand même tu voyages combien
de fois par année en avion dernièrement
zéro mais zéro mais genre deux fois par
année maintenant c'est déjà beaucoup été
moi aussi je fais ça là moi j'ai pas de
shop
en Europe tu prends mes décisions
mettons pour essayer de en tout cas
d'avoir le moins d'impact possible
jusqu'où je suis prêt à faire mais mes
choix maintenant mais mais de cette de
cette
asper environnementaliste vient aussi
l'idée de d'aimer ça être dans le bois
PMSA est dans le bois moi je peux dire
je me sens pas bien à Montréal jamais je
revenais à Québec parce que justement je
trouve Montréal c'était trop densifié
c'était trop intense puis là je moi si
je m'achète une maison je veux pas
qu'elle soit
dans le béton fait que genre deux cet
esprit là dire j'aime seul la nature je
veux sauver la planète mais je veux
aussi vivre dans le bois il y a comme ça
que tu te limite le transport envers la
ville ouais c'est ça c'est plus ça c'est
ça exactement
de la destruction d'un milieu que ça
implique plus d'infrastructures pour se
rendre parce que ça aussi c'est que la
la la quand tu crées un nouveau quartier
en banlieue puis tu crées une nouvelle
route là c'est toutes les TACs payés qui
paient pour cela tout le monde c'est pas
que pourquoi on ferait ça non mais c'est
vrai tu sais c'est l'enfant je finance
ta maison pas cher
si je pourrais financer du logement
social à la place tu as raison
effectivement c'est puis ça ça va ben
c'est le prix des maisons ok il y a ça
aussi bon bref
environnement gros gros enjeux le Parti
libéral on a pas parlé du Parti libéral
dans en tant qu' environnement là il se
positionne où dans ce dans le débat ça
me donne plusieurs fois le thé en
l'hydrogène vert il faut voir ça une
occasion de développement économique
incroyable pour le Québec et
l'environnement c'est pas juste la seule
qui parlait du trajet noir les personnes
d'autres
vraiment pour elle c'est du
développement économique l'environnement
les experts en environnement on dit
c'est pqpqs excellent plan les deux il y
en a qui disent que un ou l'autre est
meilleur mais bref les deux les deux on
les plans vraiment crédible de climat
probablement les meilleurs qu'on a
jamais eu dans une action québécoise
avec dans le code QS un petit peu plus
de sacrifices que le PQ probablement
mais
celui du PLK c'est bon on est on est
dans le dans le mardi et le
développement économique avec
l'environnement
l'hydrogène vers l'idée c'est que on
peut produire de l'hydrogène avec nos
centrales parce qu'on a beaucoup de
centrales potentiellement mais il faut
en construire beaucoup de centrales pour
avoir vraiment beaucoup d’étrangins de
base c'est ça que le goût dit en glace
mais la CAQ disait
donner le nombre de turbines que ça
prendrait le calculer à la CAQ si genre
ça prendrait une turbine à chaque à
chaque genre kilomètres jusqu'à
rouynoranda
ensuite tu peux répondre à ton
électrification des transports puis la
vente à New York sans vraiment investir
dans le
l'économie d'énergie ça va coûter cher
aussi
donc
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt dans ce
sens-là et le programme libéral mais
c'est ça que j'ai retenu c'est vraiment
l'idée d'un espèce de l'hydrogène vert
c'est quoi c'est de l'hydrogène qui
produit avec l'hydroélectricité puis
apparemment ça peut servir à j'en faire
avancer des avions puis des choses
comme
ça serait potentiellement efficace mais
franchement je prends un je sais qu'il y
a des débats là dessus
c'est de de à quel point c'était
efficace ou quoi
puis bon ils veulent des crédits
d'impôts de rénovation
pour les maisons ouais pour rendre ce
plus écho responsable
c'est pour savoir un peu de cash là ok
on parle les investissements de QS et du
PQ sont conséquents c'est des gros
investissements transports en commun tu
es investit beaucoup dans les
infrastructures vers l'environnement
puis pas la crainte de dire il y a plein
de prolongements à l'autoroute qui font
pas avec un gouvernement QS là c'est
vraiment de dire ben on prend le cash
qu'on aurait mis dans les autoroutes on
le met avant le transport en commun
parce que ce qui est assez intéressant
c'est que c'est vrai quand tu regardes
le Plan québécois des infrastructures tu
as encore plus de dépenses dans les
routes que dans les transports en commun
et le à mon ami on est loin là on est
loin de la tension environnementale
et demi dans le trafic à chaque matin
puis c'est sur son but d'envie il a
raison si les alternatives efficaces
électriques ou plus ou moins
de transport en commun les gens vont les
prendre
mais
il m'intéresse
sont épouvantables ce matin je sais pas
quand l'émission sort mais ce matin
c'est c'était
PLK 3e en égalité avec le PQ et le Parti
conservateur donc potentiellement
dernier en intention de votre caca 40 %
de 14 on pourrait se ramasser une
situation finale à tout le monde à 15
sauf laque ça ça pourrait être ça
pourrait être intéressant
puis donc c'est la pire campagne de
l'histoire du PQ probablement depuis que
je sais que des peut-être que ça s'est
passé mal en 1910 là
et ici sont rendus
5 et 10% chez les francophones mais
c'est épouvantable et ici c'est un parti
qui semble avoir pas vraiment de
direction dans ses promesses c'est assez
intéressant de regarder il y a comme des
il y a comme des hausses d'impôts pour
les riches mais des bases d'impôts pour
le monde aussi quand même riche tu as
des trucs pour les plus pauvres en même
temps que
c'est pas très cohérent ça fait c'est
comme s'il y avait essayé de reprendre
un peu le PlayBook de Trudeau en 2015
avec comme on fait de la dépense
publique en la mettant sur le déficit
non c'est parti de l'austérité c'est
comme surprenant
ils vont ils se financent beaucoup en
lutte contre l'évasion fiscale puis en
taxer les méchants les gafams les
paradis psycho tout ça sûrement parce
que Marwa risky qui est comme une
spécialiste de la lutte de l'évasion
fiscale pense qu'elle va aller chercher
beaucoup d'argent mais comme ils vont
chercher beaucoup d'argent là sur les
Lille l'évasion fiscale à 1.5 milliards
c'est pas mal de ça c'est ce qui estime
capable d'aller chercher nous quand on
avait Éric Girard à Citroën je dis le
monde pense que c'est mine d'or
l'évasion fiscale mais c'est pas tant
que ça mais l'évasion fiscale des
méchants moi j'avais vu en en
2015 l'évasion fiscale des méchantes
compagnies là c'était 800 millions
la meilleure lutte à l'évasion fiscale
qui a été faite au Québec c'est quand
qui ont mis les machines d'un restaurant
c'était genre 2 milliards par année
c'est souvent l'évasion fiscale ça veut
souvent dire genre le travail au noir
mais bon bonne chance donc il y a quand
même une grosse bouse de trucs pour les
plus pauvres pour les aînés il y a
beaucoup d'argent dans la programmée
dans le programme libéral il y a ce
fameux programme de psychothérapie
et
il y a comme on garde le fond des
générations mais on finance toutes nos
promesses sur la dette un peu wild et
puis
c'est ça on se ramasse avec un gros
déficit à la fin
puis on baisse beaucoup les taxes donc
bon ça ça va moi je trouve ça donne un
peu dans toutes les directions c'est le
fun d'avoir moi j'aime le programme PQ
par exemple il dit on voit ça on a trop
de trucs on va les financer de même le
programme de QS qui est quand même on y
va aller on change d'air
là qui dit écoute on fait rien mais
c'est comme honnête
ou les conservateurs ils sont comme nous
on s'en fout on veut juste pas d'état
c'est comme clair le seul le parti qui a
le programme pas clair c'est le PLQ Jean
je ne comprends pas où est-ce qu'ils
s'en vont c'est comme c'est vraiment pas
cohérent
je pense que les électeurs s'en rendent
compte un peu c'est comme pas ça fait un
peu coin de table puis d'ailleurs on
fait plein d'erreurs dans leur calcul
c'est sorti plusieurs fois c'est cette
semaine les dans les dernières semaines
que ils se trompait dans leurs estimes
d'être public à la fin ça c'est Rohff
quand même quand tu fais un budget puis
qu'il y a des erreurs qui sont pointés
du doigt par les autres partis
professionnel
c'est c'est plus le PLQ du temps
qui était vraiment une ministre des
Finances comme crédible il y en a eu des
bons on a des ministres des Finances
c'est Carlos et on peut ne pas l'aimer
mais c'est un bon ministre des Finances
là ici de quoi qui parle là c'est moins
clair
mettons qu'on allait dire j'allais dire
un sujet qu'on dirait qu'on a moins
parlé ou peut-être que moi j'en ai moins
entendu parler cette année c'est
l'éducation on dirait est-ce que est-ce
que c'est un enjeu qui intéresse moins
le monde est-ce que c'est juste ma
perception non mais c'est vrai il y en a
pas parlé tant que ça puis
il y a pas de promesses il y a beaucoup
de petites promesses d'amélioration
par-ci par-là du système éducatif
mais il y a pas de grosse promesse qu'on
retient effectivement en retenez vous
maintenant pas du tout
il y en a des problèmes justement dans
les écoles tes enseignants il y a des
élèves qui ont quatre enseignants dans
la même année parce que tout le monde
part en burn out ou bien tu sais ça
c'est pas un milieu qui qui va si bien
que ça puis je comprends pas pourquoi
que on sait pas plus attardé à cette
question là non effectivement j'ai tout
un astu sorti des des points
il y a des petits programmes un peu
partout là dans les dans les programmes
des partis mettons un PQ il propose
en éducation
les gros les gros programmes qui sont
proposés dans beaucoup par beaucoup de
parties c'est vraiment côté CPE ça il
semble y avoir même la CAQ veut quand
même pas mal d'investissements pour
convertir des privés en CPE
et le PQ va avoir plus proposer puis que
propose beaucoup d'argent au lycée
vraiment compléter le réseau
mais sinon
fin du financement des écoles
religieuses le PQ vraiment pas ça les
écoles religieuses
mais c'est vrai tu es une enseignante en
ce moment ou un enseignant comme avec
une charge de travail comme un débile
avec des conditions vraiment difficiles
puis qui a tentant aucun parti parler de
qu'est-ce qui compte ça peut être tu
sens de côté en fait carrément écoute il
y a vraiment pas de grosses de grosses
promesses en éducation si je pense que
tout le monde sait qu'ils veulent comme
embaucher plus de profs mais il y a pas
des budgets vraiment conséquents qui
sont proposés
[Musique]
un peu nulle part franchement
même Cuet ça peut par exemple de
gratuité scolaire dans son programme le
PQ un truc du genre quand même ironique
ouais c'est quand même ironique mais
la gratuité scolaire ça coûte 23 cher
parce que ça vaut c'est ça l'affaire je
pense qu'ils ont fini par s'en rendre
compte grâce à scolaire ça coûte comme
un milliard de dollars si tu veux
améliorer l'accès à l'éducation là il
faut investissent dans le primaire dans
le secondaire bien avant ton milliard de
dollars là ton milliard de dollars il va
être bien plus efficace en s'assurant
que le y ait pas de décrochage si ton
but c'est d'améliorer l'accès à
l'éducation c'est pas à pied je veux
dire
à quel point il y a une barrière à
l'accès en ce moment là je compte une
autre et presque scolarité mais la
baisse ça va tu vraiment améliorer
l'accès avoir et par exemple un PQ ça
j'aime la petite il y a une petite
mesure que vraiment pas très cher c'est
gratifi scolaire pour les étudiants
gratuits quand même universitaire pour
les étudiants dont les parents gagnent
moins que le revenu médian
ce que ça prouve écoute pas cher ça
mesure là ce que ça prouve c'est qu'il y
en a pas tant que ça des étudiants que
dans leurs parents sont
exact
c'est ça c'est qu'il y en a pas tant que
ça fait que bon moi je me dis c'est ça
tu peux faire des mesures ciblées pour
améliorer l'accès à certaines personnes
ce qu'on ce qui me désole un peu c'est
qu'il y a pas de débat sur la place du
privé au secondaire
[Musique]
du public c'était l'idée c'est que tu
pourrais avoir un meilleur réseau public
si tu avais plus d'étudiants qui
viennent de famille plus aisés puisqu'il
réussissent généralement mieux ou juste
d'étudiants qui sont meilleurs à l'école
qui se ramassent tous au privé en
améliorant puisque les études sont
démontrées éducation ces gens ben
ton niveau des meilleurs et pas vraiment
diminuer lorsqu'ils sont avec les moins
bons mais le niveau des moins bons est
vraiment amélioré lorsqu'ils sont avec
les meilleurs et donc on diminuerait les
inégalités en éducation qui se répercute
ensuite sur des inégalités de revenus
moi je pense que c'est la si on voulait
réduire les inégalités ce sera la
meilleure chose à faire pour pas cher
c'est juste que unifier ça
il y a plusieurs propositions il y a un
organisme j’avais écrit un article dans
Le Devoir là-dessus je trouvais que
c'est vraiment une bonne proposition un
organisme ça s'appelle l'école ensemble
avait proposé l'idée de on fait juste
subventionné à 100% privé mais on les
empêche en échange de cette subvention à
100% de sélectionner les élèves puis là
on fait un espèce de
sélection géographique comme au primaire
moi bon sélection géographique ou
aléatoire peu importe
l'important c'est là l'idée c'est que
les écoles privées
deviendraient sauf et celles qui ne
veulent pas embarquer dans ce système-là
ne recevraient plus souvent pourraient
donc rebeuf pourraient continuer à
sélectionner ses élèves mais le coût
serait très très élevé dit pour y aller
c'est se passionner à 100% donc est-ce
que ta compréhende donc
là il y a plus de barrières à l'entrée
privée et tu peux plus en mettre aussi
les écoles un peu plus choisir
une école privée en ce sens sur ces
écoles là on leur propre conseil
d'administration peut faire les trucs
différemment peuvent mettre l'uniforme
s'ils veulent que peuvent décider des
programmes un peu différents peuvent
gérer leur école la manière qui veulent
donc on garde l'idée que le privé est
innovateur genre c'est pas faux je pense
que les écoles privées il y en a qui ont
une très très bonne job donc on garde ça
c'est juste qu'ils peuvent plus
sélectionner les élèves et qui vont être
s'ils sont meilleurs ça sera pas parce
qu'on est meilleurs élèves ça va être
parce que
la qualité de du réseau pour tout le
monde je pense mais il y a pas de
proposition par rapport à ça
il y a pas confiance puis
dans les temps actuel des choses parce
que j'enverrai mon enfant publique
à Montréal
c'est c'est peut-être dommage mais
ça semble pas être il y a tellement de
problèmes en ce moment que c'est ça
je veux quand on regarde les
revenus les sources de revenus principal
de que chaque partie propose on vient de
parler de dépenses puis d'investissement
comme d'où charge d'où est-ce que cet
argent-là provient parce que c'est les
gens qui nous écoutent puis moi aussi
quand on parce que souvent mettons dans
le débat atve c'est un dit quelque chose
puis le goût c'est pas possible ça
ou le prenez-vous cet argent-là
mais c'est que c'est ça aussi ça
stratégie électorale c'est de dire c'est
que c'est vraiment eux ils veulent se
dire nous on continue c'est pas gauche
droite là c'est vraiment juste statu quo
puis de dire que
QS puis perte conservateur c'est
impossible puis de pas parler des autres
en gros il veut il veut juste jamais du
bien
je suis François Legault sur Twitter
puis toutes ces publications sont
dirigées vers sur la pcq ou québecueil
c'est ça la stratégie c'est évident ils
veulent se dire il mentionne pas la
réalisation par les extrêmes nous on est
le bon centre c'est ça leur idée puis
sur les revenus ben lac les revenus ça
provient de la baguette magique à
François c'est que François il y a des
idées que la croissance allait être plus
élevée grâce à lui parce que ça c'est
intéressant parce que c'est son
installer c'est vraiment la baguette
magique à croissance c'est son ministère
des Finances qui a fait des projections
de croissance c'est Eric Girard le fait
les projections de croissance la
vérificatrice générale a dit oui c'est
des bonnes projections de croissance
mais là dans leur programme électoral il
y a ben nous
ces nombrejections on la met on va
battre nos projections parce que nous on
sait comment créer de la richesse c'est
parce que il y en a qui savent il y en a
qui savent pas c'est il y en a qui ont
une bonne baguette magique à croissance
il y en a qui leur baguettes magiques à
croissance et pas bonne mais ça c'est
débile je veux dire personne c'est
comment créer de la croissance
facilement même à court terme genre tu
peux pas la prochaine année pas de
baguette magique à croissance là ok mais
il y a pas les autres qui proposent pas
il y a pas de nouvelles entrées d'argent
il y a pas de nous rien non il y a la
baguette magique à croissance
il y a pas plus d'impôts il y a pas plus
d'attaque c'est pas plus de il y a pas
plus de rien vraiment ils vont baisser
les impôts pour le financer ils vont
péter dans dettes
voilà
puis non puis tu sais c'est pas de la
gestion un super responsable à mon avis
parce que on va avoir besoin de cette
marge de manœuvre de pas avoir trop de
dettes publiques quand ça va commencer à
coûter cher en santé puis que genre il
va falloir réparer des routes en
Gaspésie qui viennent de s'effondrer là
c'est bon fait ça c'est le
continuons avec la baguette magique à
croissance à François ça j'aime bien ça
et ensuite les conservateurs
en dérèglementant il crée de l'argent
c'est Nice hein
quand tu la déréglementes il y a de
l'argent qui apparaît ça je savais pas
ça se défend pas en disant qui est
résolateur de l'État
moins de dépenses justement de
fonctionnaires de bureaucratie de tout
ça donc tu fais des économies c'est
peut-être ça dans le fond c'est
peut-être qu'ils ont coupé des
fonctionnaires enfin qui mais couper 4
milliards de fonctionnaires là
fonctionnaire c'est beaucoup de
fonctionnaires
[Musique]
par année puis on sait pas si c'est quoi
exactement on sait pas ce que ça veut
dire nécessairement
l'exploitation des des compétiteurs
faciles
mais ça rapporte juste en 75 millions ok
c'est fou pareil
c'est on coupe rien là mais on va juste
faire de la pression et il y a la
méchante bureaucratie qui cherche de
l'argent prendre l'argent puis que il y
a comme on peut comme aller chercher du
Grol dans le bureaucratie qui est pas
bien c'est super facile à faire c'est
juste que les gens ont pas la volonté de
le faire
nous ont jamais essayé de couper dans le
grand
astérité de Bouchard l'austérité de
Charret le stérilité de Couillard ça
c'est pas coupé dans le groupe
il y a personne ok avec la révision de
programme de couleur là ça c'est pas
fait
bon fait que et ensuite c'est qu'ils
disent finalement c'est que
il considère pas le fait que les
dépenses de santé coûtent comme tout le
temps plus cher fait ils vont couper
comme des malades là c'est ça que ça
veut dire mais moi écoute ça pas de sens
franchement c'est cohérent si tu veux
moins d'étapes et moins de taxes un bon
parti c'est juste que ça va la
projection sur la dette publique est
fausse parce qu'ils disent que ils vont
tellement être en mesure de couper que
il y aura c'est eux qui ont le meilleur
dette à la fin mais c'est tellement du
wishful tinking là il pourra pas couper
autant que ça là c'est dur couper là
mais oui
quelqu'un qui a quelque chose mais
enlever quelque chose à quelqu'un c'est
qu'on parlait des médecins plutôt c'est
aussi parce que le monde aime ça
bonne chance là il coupe pas mal pas mal
plus que le stérilité de Couillard
effectivement
au total sur son mandat c'est 2 % de
croissance le ça va être pas mal
les libéraux eux comme je vous disais
ils ont comme il y a besoin impôts pour
les super riches 350 millions toi tant
que ça c'est là qu'on se rencontre que
taxi juste les riches ça c'est augmenter
les impôts pour les gens qui gagnent à
300000 plus c'est ça donne pas ton
argent parce qu'il y en a pas tant que
ça ça c'est le petit enjeu eux ils ont
ils ont une grosse que celle de la CAQ
c'est là que et meilleur mais ils vont
essayer de donner de l'argent pauvre
c'est quand même bon particulier
avec les luttes contre les paradis
fiscaux taxe sur les immeubles d'en
occuper ça c'est aussi une idée de QS
mais plus d'argent que tu es avec ça
sur les institutions financières en fait
les libéraux il y a beaucoup de on
baisse les impôts puis on taxe les
méchants
moi je trouve pas ça super cohérent dans
le sens où c'est pas si facile que cette
accélération puis comme
les impôts
de leur mesure en terme de ils vont
aider les travailleurs d'expérience à
rester sur le marché du travail là ça ça
génère plein d'argent
c'est pas fou mais en même temps bon ou
avec les CPE il y a plus de personnes
qui travaillent fait qu'on ait plus
d'argent c'est pas fou mais ils ont
comme tricher un peu sur le programme
avec ça
et sinon
ils vont taxer les insurgent financières
aussi taxer les gafam ça c'est les deux
populaires ça revient pas mal
ils vont ils vont couper les bons ils
vont aller chercher de l'argent en
médecin en enlevant l'incorporation ce
qui est le médecin peuvent se déclarer
comme une corporation ça coûte 250
millions par année
ils vont taxer l'eau pour les
entreprises ils vont lutter contre les
profits détournés ils vont taxer la
spéculation immobilière aussi ces taxes
sur les méchants franchement c'est là
que écoute on peut chez Orly sur le
programme de QS mais leur proposition de
revenus
ils génèrent l'argent pour vrai puis OK
si on y revient c'est les derniers qu'on
va faire
ils vont taxer le monde
ils ont une idée de l'impôt sur les
grandes fortunes et les successions
d'abord faut se rendre compte les
héritages sont taxés au Québec en ce
moment c'est juste que personne ne sait
mais quand tu meurs tu es bien on
considère que tu disposes tes biens et
donc la plus-value qu'il y a été générée
mettons à des actions tu as acheté du
Apple il valait 10 pièces va être la
personne qui reçoit ton héritage va
payer la différence de la différence
avec un gain en capital puis en ce
moment le gain capital est imposé à la
moitié donc ça veut dire que c'est la
moitié du gain capital serait tout sur
ton impôt sur le revenu donc si ton
impôt sur le revenu te mette quand même
100000 dans le fond tu vas payer 50 tu
vas payer 25 % sur ce que tu reçois en
héritage c'est pas 25% maximum de
l'héritage que tu reçois autrement
maximum eux ils veulent faire que ça
soit 35
ça c'est le premier truc ça représente
quoi en terme de revenus potentiels
impôt sur les grandes fortunes qui est
l'idée que pas à chaque million que tu
as en haut d'un million tu payes 1000
pièces ça rapporte
ensuite bon il y a des possibilités
d'évitement que je suis pas convaincu
qui ont vraiment calculé moi je pense
que leurs impôts rapportent de l'argent
mais un petit peu moins probablement
parce que le monde évite l'impôt surtout
quand ils sont riches plus terrifié
l'impôt
il y a beaucoup l'idée dans la plupart
des programmes c'est que on va vous
donner des choses on va pas vous taxer
moi personnellement je pense que pour
avoir des choses pourtant le monde le
monde
soit tu as moins de choses
je pense que siqs réussit à mettre de
l'avance il met de l'avant son programme
soit ils vont devoir dépenser moins soit
ils vont devoir taxer le monde pas vrai
j'aurais pu tout le monde parce que ils
font les trucs un peu bizarres avec leur
impôts ils baissent l'impôt de 80 pièces
pour tout le monde qui gagne en bas de
90 000 mais pour faire ça ils vont comme
augmenter beaucoup l'impôt du monde en
90 000 le genre on deviendrait
l'endroit dans le monde où l'impose le
revenu le plus élevé
ça c'est dangereux pour
pour que les gens veulent pas venir ici
les
meilleurs revenus moi je crois pas à
l'argument que les gens viennent pas les
entreprises oui c'est là qu'ils vont
chercher comme beaucoup d'argent sur les
entreprises au total 4.6 milliards
c'est peut-être un peu risqué mais les
gens les gens ils viennent pas les gens
ils partent pas d'ici parce qu'ils sont
taxés plus là non mais maintenant
quelqu'un qui voudrait venir ici puis
que l'information qui a c'est que le
Québec c'est la place dans le monde où
est-ce que les impôts sont les plus
élevés pour le revenu mais ouais parce
que ensuite en France et puis au
Danemark les impôts sont plus élevés
ça dépend c'est sûr si donne un job à
30000 viendra pas mais si tu lui donnes
une grosse job à 300000 bonbons qui
paient 5000 pièces ou plus là la
distinction que tu fais impôt sur le
revenu versus impôts des entreprises bah
il y a les taxes à la consommation qui
demeure relativement basse ici par
rapport à l'Europe où il y a les
cotisations comme par exemple ta
cotisation d'assurance emploi ici on
l'utilise beaucoup moins qu'en Europe
donc nous on a une taxation qui est sur
l'impôt sur le revenu mais on n'a pas
beaucoup de cotisations ou de taxe à la
consommation
mais donc
c'est ça fait que en imposant les riches
en baissant n'est pas un peu de tout le
monde c'est 1.3 milliards
tout le monde là-dessus le 80 pièces que
tu donnes à tout le monde ça sert un peu
rien ça fait que tu dois comme taxi
encore plus les plus riches puis comme
c'est pas clair que ça va générer tant
d'argent que ça
il y a des
ils veulent taxer plus de l'entreprise
pour 2.4 - 2.6 milliards c'est quand
même pas mal et
[Musique]
d'entreprises et cette fameuse taxe sur
le capital est intéressante était
vraiment mal communiqué gérardment vu de
la communication c'est pourri
les super riches le monde
un calcul et probablement mauvais de
dire que c'est juste 5 % de la
population parce que genre tous les
policiers sont inclus le sont contre le
régime de retraite qui ont une maison
c'est ça commence
c'est vrai que c'est un mauvais spin
il me semble je suis pas
ultérieure net tu es relativement riche
mais c'est le bain du monde qui ont 60
ans qui sera en à ce niveau-là c'est
c'est ça qui se passe dans vie là on
parle de la mesure qui serait
à partir de 2 millions de 1 million de 2
il y avait l'histoire des fermes que
c'est vrai que bon
ça c'était pas leur meilleur move mais
l'idée en tant que tel
le monde là son vraiment plus riches en
valeur nette maintenant que dans les
années 80 mais c'est juste pas également
distribué mais donc pistache Jean là on
n'est pas allé la chercher là
il y a beaucoup de monde qui valent un
million tu peux leur demander mais
Pierre pour aller chercher deux points 6
milliards c'est quand même Nice c'est
juste que mal communiqué c'est un peu
compliqué là moi je l'aurais fait de
plus simple que ça mais quand tu dis ben
on va taxer le gars en capital plus
d'attiles
là c'est un peu compliqué de demander au
monde de faire leur petite facture
d'aller checker toute ta valeur pour
payer à la fin probablement pas 1000
pièces
vont valoir genre 1 point 2 faites-le
pour donner 200 pièces à l'état ça va te
prendre genre une journée de travail
c'est un peu comme ça
sera plus simple de même genre cont tout
le monde doit l'année 2004 tout le monde
déjà mettons dans ton rapport d'impôts
franchement
si ton régime de retraite c'est pas
genre ton réel parce que oui ton réel
c'est vrai que c'est pas compliqué
un peu une fois par année genre sont où
le thé
financier toi
tu peux acheter une fois par année
puis ta maison est un juste à prendre
les comptes de taxes là
une valeur estimée puis ça sera ça puis
c'est juste le fond de pension c'est
quand même un peu compliqué
titre de ton employeur je sais pas
combien qu'il vaut donc c'est pas
[Musique]
c'est compliqué que ça non mais c'est
une étape de plus dans une vie occupée
ça pourrait être plus simple genre en
Scandinavie tu payes des impôts par
message texte c'est malade les trucs
calculs pour toi puis ça c'est ce qu'on
pense que tu dois tu devrais tu dis oui
fini
c'est bien plus simple à faire c'est que
leur impôts se passe simplifier il y a
pas de crédit d'impôt presque puis date
c'est déjà ok j'aime ça
j'aime bien mon comptable mais pas tant
que sauver de cette partie là de ma vie
ce serait vraiment un petit
[Musique]
peu limité
les contacts
avec Gilles moi c'est Sylvain
toutes les parties ont on leur programme
offre différentes choses je pense qu'on
a fait un bon panorama là depuis le
début de la conversation est-ce que il y
a
un budget qui ou des budgets qui se
tiennent pas tantôt mettons que le plus
puis les moins ça marche pas dans ton de
ton avis de ceux qu'on a vu c'est sûr
que la CAQ c'est celui qui tient le plus
parce que
c'est pas compliqué là il propose une
petite baisse d'impôts puis une petite
dépense pour les personnes plus âgées
sont réalisables parce que
c'est quand même je te propose rien neuf
qu'on continue
ensuite c'est sûr que même à ça
il y a pas tant de prêter s'il y a une
récession qui est plus grave qu'on pense
ça va changer complètement la plateforme
pour toutes les parties
ensuite toutes les parties ont comme des
trucs un peu optimiste genre le PQ le il
considère que leur mesure va générer pas
mal d'argent assez rapidement ce qui est
pas impossible mais ça se peut que c'est
ton effet des CPAS sur le marché du
travail ça peut être relativement long
les faits de augmenter la participation
du marché du travail des personnes plus
ça peut prendre un certain temps à quel
point on va le voir les libéraux ils ont
beaucoup de sont très optimistes sur
leur capacités à attaquer les paradis
fiscaux
EQs sont très optimistes sur la capacité
des la volonté les personnes plus riches
et des entreprises de ne pas éviter les
taxes qu'ils vont leur proposer et que
ça du côté des entreprises n'aura pas
d'effets négatifs tant que ça sur la
croissance donc il y a beaucoup
d'optimisme dans toutes ces promesses-là
aussi bon moi je sais pas convaincuqs
veut avec Pharma Québec que ça va
rapporter qu'à plusieurs milliards de
dollars à l'état l'idée de faire un
Québec c'est de créer une espèce de
programme public de d'assurance
médicament
comme pas sûr que ça rapporte de
l'argent
surtout si on calcule que mettons il y a
des
par mois Québec ça rapporte deux points
7 milliards
c'est si ça rapporte 2.7 milliards il y
a des entreprises pharmaceutiques qui
payent moins d'impôts Québec dans le
sens où ils vont comme plus pauvre parce
qu'il y a quand même beaucoup d'initiés
pharmaceutiques qui payent quand même
des impôts
et
aussi par exemple un PQ va chercher un
milliard en tapant ses médecins
optimiste la carte avait proposé ça
aussi puis on peut être capable en quoi
le PQ plus capable que la CAQ c'est le
même gouvernement là dans le sens
gouvernement là donc tout le monde est
assez optimiste et
pas grand monde
font vraiment face aux problèmes des
finances publiques qui sont que
tes finances publiques sont dans une
posture difficile d'être dans 10 ans et
donc faudrait plus prudent
et donc si on veut proposer plus de
dépenses faudrait vraiment taxé
davantage puis on peut pas vraiment se
permettre des bases d'impôts sans les
financer en baissant les dépenses ce que
la claque propose c'est parce que la
carte qui vous dise on baisse les impôts
mais vous allez avoir une services parce
qu'on le pèle dans dettes ce qui est pas
oui la situation de la dette publique
s'est améliorée mais elle on a besoin
d'être publique faible pour plus tard
quand on va avoir des soins de santé
trop cher mais là on fera des déficites
mais c'est pas une bonne idée de de en
ce moment là on a une bonne situation
financière gardons là le tout le monde
comme pas dépenses toute la marge de
manœuvre qui existe en ce moment sans
aller chercher vraiment les revenus
nécessaires à peu près tout le monde a
un gap de revenus dépenses d'aujourd'hui
milliards
ce qui est pas
ce qui est pas prudent personne n'est
prudent mais c'est une campagne latérale
les gens des campagnes électorales
peuvent être prudent toujours optimiste
dans le sens qu'après ça si on le vu le
mettons qu'ils font l'analyse de des
premiers tenues par les gouvernements on
sait jamais 100% c'est non mais c'est
quand même toujours élevé pour justement
le livre dont je parlais tout à l'heure
c'est c'est sur ça là c'est on regarde
les promesses tenues puis c'est quand
même élevé il y en a que tu te rends
compte que ça marche pas mais c'est le
saladier médecin
ou que finalement tu peux pas réformer
le scrutin le mode électoral ce qui
d'ailleurs effectivement côté CAC ça
leur est nu et avoir une proportionnelle
bah c'est sûr qu'il devrait être en
collection avec le PQ après sélection là
donc parce qu'il serait plus
représentatif par contre on le voit
clairement si on amène une réforme
électorale comme l'élection serait déjà
décidé mais ce serait une coalition pq4
qui aurait plus que 50% des votes très
représentant représentatif de ce que les
gens veulent tu penses que le PQ tu
penses que c'est leur seul partenaire de
coalition avec
Us non
[Musique]
il finirait à 35 37 38 il y a pas de
majorité bah il devrait s'appuyer sur un
autre des parties et puis le parti le
plus proche et le PQ ce que les libéraux
à gauche puis le pcq tu peux pas
t'habiller avec ça
c'est sûr
il avait proposé la réforme du mode de
scrutin c'est comme c'est quand c'est
une fois que tu gagnes mais finalement
ça marche pas moi qui était lui mais ça
marche bien c'est triste mais c'est
c'est
intéressant
le monde se battent pas des autobus
quand le monde se battre dans autobus
pourquoi genre
autobus que si tu veux plus gentil
tu parlais pour les Québécois ça
intéresse
[Rires]
on pensait que ça allait être plate mais
on voit comme il y a une décision à
prendre pour qui qui va être la position
officielle puis c'est majeur parce que
bon le pcq peut pas le light mais
pourrait quand même finir deuxième en
terme d'intention de vote tu as pédicule
en fait sont très concentrés dans
certaines régions au LACAQUE est très
forte donc est-ce que tu aimes avoir un
siège ça va être la ça va être
intéressant
et le PQ plus fort qu'on pensait moi je
pensais que c'était à la fin du PQ c'est
la fin des haricots dans cette élection
mais leur chef a un bon travail puis une
bonne plateforme
vraiment pour qui j'avais jamais pensé
qui sont pas les PQ qui après le débat
en fait
[Musique]
beau aussi solide dans des bas et puis
QS propose comme un programme qui est
mais c'est sûr que pas toute réaliser si
ils sont au pouvoir mais c'est un
programme qui vraiment répond au
problème environnementaux qui
leur est satisfait à leur électorat qui
dans le pense va aller chercher l'argent
à te vendre plus riche qui sont plus
vieux
le temps donc on va avoir un autre qui
va avoir un bon score
puis les libéraux vont tellement nulle
part que ça c'est intéressant de voir le
à quel point à quel point jusqu'où ils
vont aller le jusqu'où ils vont aller il
fait que c'est le pécu au monde de 2% il
peut finir à bosser officiel on est
rendu là si les libéraux de 10 minutes 2
puis tu vois ça maintient c'est
peut-être QS qui font la position
officielle tout le monde va avoir entre
15 sièges le max le mien c'est quand
même une soirée électorale intéressante
ça c'est moi je pense que la campagne
parce que c'est ensuite il va devoir y
avoir une reconfiguration de
l'opposition pour 2026
puissance en opposition officielle va
être forcé de se modérer
s'ils veulent être leading gouvernement
en attente et alors que le pays le cul
va peut-être se complaire un peu en
opposition officielle mais en même temps
ils vont devoir aussi quand même
réfléchir au fait que là ça va être la
pirection de l'histoire
et le PQ qui meurt pas ça devient plus
difficile la recomposition des forces de
l'opposition aussi donc c'est c'est
quelque chose d'assez intéressant puis
on voit que le goût
plus c'est l'amplui par des votes moi je
me dis papa il se représente ça en 2026
il y a géré le Québec pendant pandémie
tout le monde est contre lui tout le
temps
il y avait la tu voyais
la socoop était sur le point de
l'explorer
l'action mais il accepte littéralement
aucune entrevue
sur aucun plateau tu sais je pense que
j'ai dû voir toutes les chefs de tous
les partis sur toutes les réseaux ils
vont partout même rad de Radio-Canada en
fait genre entrevue avec tous les chefs
Peter tous les chefs le seul qui est pas
là c'est le goût mais j'ai l'impression
que c'est parti la stratégie de genre
le moins tu mets les pieds d'un plat le
mieux pourtant il fait quand même bien
c'est ça à chaque fois qu'il parle
moins le moins tu parles mieux c'est on
va juste être on va juste essayer d'en
perdre la moins possible
d'avoir le goût d'être là mais on va le
voir au début de jeudi c'est ça c'est un
débat différent j'ai l'impression c'est
ça quand ça va sortir normalement ça va
être déjà passé
une énorme performance
on parlait justement puis hors de tout
penchant pour un parti politique puis
les idées de lac puis quoi que ce soit
c'est objectivement
le policier le moins charismatique que
j'ai que j'ai eu à avoir depuis que
j'étais un ange de voter en ce moment
j'ai jamais vu ça j'ai écouté à matin un
petit reportage de radio-cannes sur
Verdun on s'est rendu série c'est ça
c'est rendu super serré en QS puis la
calque
est censé gagner en plus
au Québec ça c'est souvent le même dans
le sens où c'est si tu regardes le
niveau de langage de nos débats par
rapport à mettons la France c'est pas
c'est plus populaire de parler mais le
coup c'est vrai qu'il s'exprime pas très
bien dans le sens où c'est pas que c'est
toi qui fait des fautes de français là
c'est laborieux un peu le son
comme un monsieur comme un monsieur il
s'exprime comme
comme genre comme un monsieur dans un
parti de famille qui va dire ah ça c'est
un plan de and world mettons-le puis que
tout le monde va faire genre
Daniel si Daniel tu peux plus dire ça tu
sais on dirait que le gars il est quand
même c'est comme tu peux pas dire ça
c'est pas ça je veux dire l'expression
t'es pas Daniel le Manon mais c'est vrai
que ça fait Daniel c'est les erreurs
son électorat c'est assez fou comment il
y a une division en ce moment vous en
avez parlé déjà probablement gagné que
les divisions d'âge là
c'est majoritaire c'est les jeunes votes
quand même seulement
pas bon je les ai comme ça
si mauvais chez les jeunes mais elles
sont pas fort non plus ça c'est assez
intéressant à voir que ça c'est pas
c'est pas bon ton potentiel de
croissance comme parti c'est là que ça
va être intéressant je pense que c'est
pas on a l'impression que la situation
politique au Québec c'est la domination
de la CAQ habite à maternelle mais 2026
le c'est dans longtemps qui peut se
passer des affaires le goût va peut-être
pas se représenter là ça va faire une
bisbée dans ce partie là c'est du plus
nationaliste c'est plus fédéraliste
c'est plus à gauche à droite c'est pas
c'est pas réglé puis est-ce qu'il y a un
les deux qui va être aussi populaire
parce qu'il est beau pour être
charismatique il est populaire comme
vous l'avez mentionné c'est pas réglé
puis est-ce que
QS va prendre la position officielle de
venir plus crédible pour la classe
moyenne pas jeune à voir est-ce que les
libéraux au contraire vont sortir comme
un chef comme qui ramène le Parti vert
quelque chose qui est plus populaire
chez les francophones parce que c'est
sûr que s'il reste en bas de 10 % chez
francophone ça
officiel puis finalement ressort de
naissance
puis est-ce que la tendance vers une
radicalisation comme on a vu aux
États-Unis il va se continuer puis que
l'ascension du parti conservatoire
québécois va continuer à aller de
l'avant des prochaines années je me
question aussi qu'on peut se poser
à droite
le CAC en fait c'est budgets là c'est
c'est très centré c'est proche de ce que
le PQ sous Bouchard faisait c'est
c'était il y avait c'est un parti qui a
dépensé plus que pas vraiment baisser
les impôts
qui étaient les dépenses en éducation a
augmenté vraiment de manière conséquente
pendant le mandat de la CAQ
et ben il y a plein d'électeurs qui se
disent ben il y a pas de partie de
droite que les consommateurs sont ceux
plus la pandémie la position de mesure
sanitaire ça laisse la se passe le moi
je trouve que c'est 5 qui soit là et ils
offrent une offre politique et vraiment
différente des autres ça c'est clair et
il c'est sûr que 15% du monde ils
pensent de même là ça serait bizarre
qu'il y en a pas 15 %. mais ensuite
est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup de potentiel
de croissance avec un parti aussi fort
au centre droit comme lac pas sur le
dessus
on suce merci beaucoup
c'était super intéressant puis on espère
que ça va être clair et nos auditeurs
allez voter c'est important c'est très
important surtout dans un riz Verdun un
Bourget la balle il y a des courses des
courses serrées mais partout allez voter
partout allez vas-y partout merci
beaucoup merci à vous